إلى روح مقاتلينا المتواجدين في غزة
ونحن نتحدث بالطبع عن المصابين والمصابين
في الجسد ولكن من الناس من جرح في الروح المخدوشة
للأبد
والليلة الماضية كانت حدثا صعبا للغاية
يمكن أن ينتهي أيضًا بكارثة بالنسبة لمقاتل في اللواء
المظليون الذين خرجوا للانتعاش بعد اللواء
المظليون هم اللواء الذي كان موجودًا لفترة أطول
داخل المنزل ولم يخرج حتى أثناء وقف إطلاق النار
المرطبات التي فعلوها للجميع تذهب إلى المنشأة لتناول المرطبات
ملجأ جمعية الجندي في عسقلان وهو
كان ينام هناك ليلاً مع أصدقائه من الوحدة
من المظليين
في الغرفة يستيقظ في منتصف الليل من كابوس
يعتقد أنه في غزة، وربما يعتقد أنه محاصر
في الحبال يمسك السلاح ويبدأ في الرؤية
وضربت الكرات الحائط لحسن الحظ في الغالب
كما أصيب عدد من أصدقائه بجروح طفيفة جراء الشظايا
كان إطلاق النار حدثًا كان من الممكن أن ينتهي بكارثة
صحيح، أعتقد أن هناك تعتيمًا كبيرًا جدًا
خروف
ليشرب
م شيوت للثور ليخسره كما هو الحال في الماضي
دور القائد أذكركم بأن القادة
إلهة المظليين هي أيضًا شركة في النهاية
صغار جدًا يبلغون من العمر 22 عامًا وهم خسارة للمجتمع
18 عامًا ولست متأكدًا من هؤلاء القادة أيضًا
في بعض الأحيان يكونون أطفالًا صغارًا وهم في نفس الوضع
نظام الضغط وما يلزم بسبب نظام الضغط
وبسبب المواقف التي يواجهونها
تشغيل نظام ثقيل جدًا من العوامل
مهنة تقوي المرونة العقلية للمحاربين
ولذلك فمن المستحيل تعزيز الثبات العقلي
المحاربون عندما يسيرون معهم داخل المنطقة ولكن
عندما تخرج للانتعاش وقبل الخروج لممارسة أي نشاط
من الممكن جلب العوامل التي من شأنها تعزيز المرونة العقلية
وسيعطون أيضًا الأدوات للقادة ليفعلوا ماذا
يقول شادي أنا لا أقول أن هذا متناقض ولكنه كذلك
ينبغي أن يكون بالفعل على مستوى
بالمناسبة، أنا أعمل اليوم في قاعدة تل هشومير
ويرفض التجنيد، ويرفض المشاركة في الحرب
لقد ارتكبتم جريمة في غزة، وأعتقد أن المجزرة لا تحل مجزرة
العنف لا يحل العنف ولهذا السبب أنا كذلك
عمارة ميساب جيزو بجوار عمارة كلنا
سوف تنفجر النوافذ
انهارت الجدران
لقد سقطوا وخرجنا بأعجوبة بإصابات طفيفة
أعتقد أنه من يوم الاثنين التاسع إلى العاشر من تيهال مفيز
لنا في كل وقت
قصف
تعال إلينا واشرح لنا
بالنسبة لطفلين يبلغان من العمر أربع سنوات، الاسم الذي يقصفهما هو هذا
والجيش هو جيشهم الذي كان من المفترض أن يحميهم
هناك في منزلهم من يعرفهم هناك الآن
يقصفهم أثناء تواجدهم بالداخل
غزة وهذا وهذا استمر ولم يتوقف وكل يوم
الذي يمر تقول حسنا لا يمكن أن يكون ذلك
ليس من المنطقي كما لو كانوا يعرفون أنهم يعرفون بالفعل
إنهم يعرفون أنني هنا يا أطفالي